y
vale
se me viene una historia realmente
porque digo muchas veces me ha sucedido
esto se me vienen historias a la cabeza
y con esas historias que viví empiezo a
construir lo que voy a decidir y lo que
voy a hacer entonces empecé a pensar una
historia que me sucedió a los 7 años yo
conocí a mi papá a los 7 años
papá llega y me invita a jugar béisbol
pase todo el día jugando béisbol con él
y en la noche cuando me entrega en casa
de mi mamá me dice hijo te voy a dar un
consejo creo que es el único que me dio
en toda la vida
pero se me quedó grabado así me acuerdo
muy bien me dijo con el perdón de todos
cuando cuando salgas a la calle porque
afuera en la vida es dura cuando salgas
a la calle dejas el corazón en la casa y
sales con los huevos en la mano
y a mis siete años yo dije pues que está
muy feo
y además es bien incómodo
después pensé ya sé por qué los hombres
siempre tengas más en las bolsas
entonces
nada se me hacía un comentario misógino
pues se me dio mala onda dices que que
machista mi papá no pasaron muchos años
para que yo pudiera entender de qué se
trataba
yo creo que hasta la vida adulta hace
como dos tres semanas puedo entender
de qué se trató eso
y creo que mi papá fue claro y
contundente y me aportó algo muy grande
en mi vida o al menos así me lo cuento
hoy
tal vez es producto de que hoy estoy
aquí
en ese momento cuando viene esta imagen
a la mente de esta historia yo dije ya
sé de qué voy a hablar voy a hablar de
historias y de cómo las historias han
configurado mi vida
y cómo interpretar mis propias historias
configuraron mi vida entonces empecé a
pensar en historias que yo quería contar
y que como les cuento algo que valga la
pena que que cuando ellos salgan de aquí
y lleguen a sus casas abran la puerta en
cuanto entren se conecten con lo que
vivieron entre text
dije necesito contar algo que sea lo
suficientemente significativo
entonces entre todo empecé a pensar en
una historia y dije así voy a contar
no sé si para ustedes no vaya a ser para
mí lo fue
cuando me casé una yo yo le pregunté a
mi esposa una semana después de casados
lo que debía haberle preguntado al menos
una semana antes
[Música]
le pregunté oye mi amor neta si sabes
cocinar
y ella con toda desfachatez me contestó
no voy tú
dije salimos porque si tú no sabes si yo
no sé pues quién quiero vamos a hacer
pero está bien fácil vamos al mercado y
vamos a ver qué hacemos nos fuimos al
mercado y empezamos a agarrar unas cosas
indispensables para lograr sopas de
vasos o las papitas fritas
y yo me acordaba que cuando vivía en
casa de mamá siempre había frutas y
verduras entonces empezamos a agarrar
frutas y verduras y las empresas más
allá del carro llegamos a la casa y como
buen marido primerizo le dije mi amor te
ayudo a acomodar y él me dijo claro que
sí dejemos el equipo pues yo empiezo a
acomodar junto con ella agarró los
plátanos y los meto al réferi entonces
mi esposa voltea y con todo ese amor de
la primera semana de matrimonio me dice
nada más hay un detalle miembro los
plátanos van afuera
y yo como era inocente le contesté y le
digo no veamos los plátanos van adentro
ella respiro profundo a filo la mirada
y me dijo alex
los plátanos en afuera
1x de buen corazón no piensa que van
haciendo y se me ocurrió volver en el
mismo sentido tocaron los plátanos buena
dentro
[Música]
respira profundo afila la mirada se
desencaja completamente y me dice
alejandro a
yo escuché el eco te lo juro
y yo sé que la vida es difícil yo lo he
pensado muchas veces pero siendo [ __ ]
es más difícil le contesté
alejandro es eso que está en el centro
de la mesa yo sí
se llama frutero
y es para colgar los plátanos que van
afuera
sí
abro el reflejo carolina veces el cajón
que dice frutas y verduras
dónde van los plátanos adentro afuera
pero no importa
yo soy de la ciudad hermosillo y a mí me
enseñaron que los platos dentro del
referí
ellos el senado
ya le enseñaron que van afuera
y yo creo que esta historia me sirve
mucho a la fecha me siguen sirviendo tal
vez nos sirvió para estar aquí hoy
[Música]
él
pensar en esto pensar en esta historia
me hizo darme cuenta que no importa lo
que está pasando afuera sino como te lo
vas contento
en el 2012
nace nace mi hija
y el día que nació cada rato me decían
si a mí me pones una foto así le
preguntaste a tu esposa porque me
pediste permiso siguió con esa foto si
te mato y que fue tanto yo quise estoy
seguro que mis padres se sentirá
orgullosa porque ese fue el día uno de
los días más especiales para nosotros el
día que nació mi hija yo la recibo y
cuando la vi
tenía tantas historias en mi cabeza
había escuchado cosas como es que es
bien difícil ser papá es también campeón
entonces en la que te metiste corre
huella entonces
[Música]
yo por años había pensado que para que
alguien te quisiera aún tenías que hacer
mucho entonces yo me había convertido en
un cuate que era muy bueno bueno
buenísimo ya todo el mundo le decía que
sí porque yo pensaba que de esa manera
la gente me podía querer pero ese día
agarra mi hija
abre un poquito sus ojos me voltea a ver
y no sé si se dan cuenta en esa imagen
me agarra el dedo y en ese momento
empecé a sentir algo tan indescriptible
no les puedo contar lo único que supe
es que no tenía que hacer nada para
recibir un chingo de amor
y eso me movió me envolvió tanto
cambió completamente el paradigma de lo
que es el amor en la vida para mí en el
2015 mi esposa y yo
estamos convencidos de que queríamos un
segundo hijo así que empezamos a hacer
la tarea machine todos los días
[Música]
y empezamos a notar ya porque queríamos
un segundo hijo así que nos enteramos en
septiembre del 2015 a que íbamos a ser
papás por segunda vez y estábamos
convencidos que eso lo que queríamos
amábamos esa idea
un lunes nos da la noticia que estamos
embarazados el miércoles damos la
noticia y el viernes yo estaba en mi
consultorio y me marca mi esposa y me
dice álex estoy teniendo un sangrado
y el perdón
pasó por ella llegó una clínica para eso
y vamos hablando por teléfono en la
clínica me estaban esperando nos estaban
esperando llegamos se acuesta la revisan
y la doctora voltea y me dice mira es
muy fácil es hasta en un aborto entonces
lo que va a proceder es lo siguiente
pasas ahorita la caja pagas 20 mil pesos
porque vamos a un legrado y pues no
sabemos cómo va a proceder ahorita bien
esto pero tuve y pagan y prepárense
porque esto es urgente
yo le dije a doctora me permite unos
minutos con mi esposa
sí claro se sale
y en ese momento
como la mano de mi esposa y con una mano
tomaba la mano de mi esposa y con otra
me agarraba los juegos literal porque
tenía un chingo de miedo y le dije
estaba temblando y uno que medio
enfrentado algo tan difícil para mí yo
creo que es de las cosas de las
experiencias más duras y más difíciles
que me enfrentado
y le digo mi amor
a mí también me está doliendo pero vamos
a hacer lo que tú quieras y me dijo me
quiero ir
vámonos de 15 mil pesos
nos vamos pero sin acercarnos llegamos
otra clínica y efectivamente estábamos
teniendo un aborto sin embargo la
historia fue muy diferente nos explican
que era un embrión y ccoo algo así
nos explican que tuvimos la mala suerte
estadísticamente de jaén en eso
y
tal vez fue muy duro muy duro para
nosotros dos meses después tres meses
después me dice mi esposa en diciembre
mi amor quiero darte las gracias porque
si tú no me hubieras tomado la mano y me
miras yo que te estaba doliendo yo creo
que me hubiera sentido muy sola
así que gracias
yo en ese momento nada más pensar en mi
papá decía gracias
porque si tuvieras enseñado a hacer esto
yo creo que yo no me hubiera atrevido
porque es tan difícil decir de repente
para mí se me hace tan difícil decir
[ __ ] mí me duele también cuando en esto
no puedo con esto y entonces abrirme y
enfrentarme a mí mismo
en el 2017 después de seguir
intentándolo mucho nace oliver
y oliver nació en medio de muchas cosas
primero los primeros tres meses teníamos
que tener un chingo de fe porque todos
uno nos decía no no no no hay nada de
sant embriónico otra vez y una semana la
tía y otra semana no le latía el corazón
una semana estaba y nos mandaban a hacer
estudios a otro lugar fuimos como a
cinco laboratorios diferentes nos
hicimos todas las pruebas y nacional
y cada vez que yo vea oliver a mí me
recuerda lo que es tener fe y
persistencia en la vida
es el historia que yo me cuento cuando
vea
hace
hace unos meses
en julio 11 de julio perdón el 22 de
agosto que me marca metas 24 de junio me
marcan y me dicen sabes que 20 en [ __ ]
tu mamá está muy mal y la tienes que
llevar a una clínica
yo estaba en una clase de surf con mi
hija así que rápido me voy para ella
duramos tres semanas en el hospital
puedo decir que dormía y digo dormía
porque nunca dormía
acompañando a mi mamá en un hospital
hasta que el 11 de julio en la mañana me
dicen tu mamá ya lleva 3 crisis
para la cuarta y no sé si sobreviva
tienes que decidir algo si le da otra
crisis tienes que leen tuve
o quieres dejarla ir
yo creo que es la decisión más difícil
que ha tomado
yo le dije permite en un instante
agarró la mano de mi mamá
ya saben quiere recordar otro mundo
y complete algo yo creo que mi mamá se
fue dando me algo muy grande
porque en ese momento
récord en 50% que yo había tomado de mi
papá vean la vida con los huevos en la
mano pero
estando con mi mamá
con la otra mano aprendí a tomar el
corazón y lo tomé grande en ese momento
para decidir no por mí o no para lo que
era más conveniente para mí aprender a
decidir por ella para lo que le convenía
a ella y la historia que me conté en ese
momento
fue que
no siempre en la vida tienes que decidir
nada más por ti va a haber veces que te
vas a tener que hacer un lado para
decidir para lo que es mejor para
alguien más así que tome su mano
sintiendo su corazón y dije ya estoy
completo a mis 37 años estoy completo
de un lado
la fuerza de mi papá
y del otro lado
el corazón de mi mamá la pasión por
hacer las cosas la disciplina por hacer
las cosas y entonces
decidí el 11 de julio se fue pero me
dejó una de las experiencias más grandes
sentirme completo sentir que mamá y papá
estaban conmigo
y hoy estoy viviendo la historia que me
conté hace 11 años es tan intensa y
enfrentándome
a lo más difícil que es hablar de mi
vida
[Música]
ellos son mis padres
y gracias a ellos estoy aquí
porque estar aquí parado desnudarme
abrirme y contarles todo esto tal vez es
de las cosas más complicadas que he
hecho si a mí me puedes pedir que
tenemos cursos
pero hablar de mí
pero que no era lo más fácil
sin embargo la historia que me conteo ya
fue que mis padres están conmigo siempre
y con eso te puedo decir en este momento
que no importa lo que sea que estés
pasando y no importa lo que estés
viviendo y no importa lo que suceda en
tu vida lo más importante siempre va a
ser la historia que te cuentes muchas
gracias